[Music]
so you all probably know that Godzilla
minus one Godzilla xcong the new Empire
and the legacy of monsters are going to
be released real soon well there is
another Godzilla that you should know
that will be showcased in the coming
weeks ahead but wait a minute didn't the
title say for Godzillas in 6 months and
we can only count three with that new
entry well strap yourselves up for this
reveal and why there are are really four
types of Godzillas that will be seen
within half a year we are going to go
one by one and the shows they are in as
well as well as the dates and recent
news regarding all of them let's get to
it the first king here is the one and
only Godzilla minus one Toho will be
screening the much anticipated Godzilla
minus one for the first time not on the
3rd of November but in Tokyo's Film
Festival which is going to be held in
the first of that month Godzilla minus 1
will be a reboot of of the original
after all these 70 years and it will be
a fresh new design a standalone and a
standup part movie from the rest it will
not be connected to the monsterverse or
the earlier Shin Godzilla Godzilla here
will be smaller in size but way more
terrifying and he will go back to the
roots you know the creation or Origins
by nuclear weaponry and testings and his
subsequent revenge on Humanity by
attacking Tokyo and here Godzilla will
be smaller around 50 m or 164 ft in
height and going by the trailers and
leaked footage he will truly be an evil
force taking Delight in killing people
if only he was available to be seen
during
Halloween the second one is Godzilla in
Legacy of the monsters as Gare Goji so
as most of us have already seen the new
full trailer well I'm guessing most of
us have so anyway the king here will be
seen as his 2014 version of design which
is called the G Goji since the show will
focus on a group of people monar the or
organization totally new monsters which
we shall Showcase in another video and
also have time jumps from 2014 back to
the past to the 1950s therefore we will
see the original legendary Godzilla
design which is Iconic with his straight
and Jagged dagger like dosal plates
remember those thick legs well we will
see them as well and that big belly GOI
with the dad bot is coming back to the
screens baby furthermore we will also
see his Evolution or transformation from
from gar Goji to the 2019 king of the
monsters design called DOA Goji thirdly
the new kid on the Block as we would
like to call him Godzilla Rex as part of
a short Godzilla versus Megalon flick to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of
megalon so Toho approved this new short
film that will feature a rematch between
megalon and the king of the monsters and
it will be screened as part of the
Godzilla Fest in Japan on November 3rd
so there is already a teaser trailer out
there and the Twitter or Expo states
that this is going to be a part of the
50th anniversary of megalon birth that
is it has been 50 years since the movie
Godzilla versus megalot of 1973 was
shown in cinemas it will be an approved
sequel to the work of takuya uishi the
guy that brought out last year's
Godzilla versus gigant Rex and it will
be in collaboration with akihiro shibata
known for gfu Godzilla and dress
whatever those two mean so these both
have teamed up to bring out a 3DC GX
life action short work so it will be
larger than the gagen Rex short film and
also include real life people in it in
conjunction with an improved CGI king of
the monsters they also stated don't miss
the Raya battle between Godzilla and
megalon meaning that since Shin Godzilla
onwards the too Godzillas are termed to
be in the Raya era succeeding the
Millennium and the hyay eras before it
and I don't think this will include the
most diverse era films since trar
Godzilla wasn't including in the H era
of movies therefore the most of us GVK
gxa and all that will not be in the Raya
eras lastly we will have Godzilla in gxk
the new Empire as a newer evolved form
of doag Goji what hang on guys let me
explain here's the thing this isn't a
leaked plot or a spoiler but an educated
inference see Godzilla in the monster
verse is Ever Changing we have the G
Goji of 2014 and after his battle with
the muto Prime what happened he evolved
into the DOA Goji with more Maple Leaf
shaped dorsal plates and then got buffed
with uh strenous chest push-ups let's
say look all I'm seeing here is that we
might just see Godzilla take on a
slightly different form from the one
that we saw in king of the monsters hell
even the one in GVK had a slight re-up
upgrade in Finn's arms feet tail and a
nuclear Powers especially him glowing
extra hard and yeah with a fight against
the original Titan and scaring he would
have to develop new skills or revamp his
entire body to come out on top hell even
a toy leak showed a drastically
different dorsal plate design of do Goji
So High Hopes on that one so those are
the four Godzillas we will see by April
of
2024 in 6 months so if you like this
video then watch this one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
monsters and creatures then check out
our Channel as well we might just have
things that you haven't seen or thought
about
like subscribe and we'll see you on the
next video take care
fam